THROUGHOUT THE NIGHT.
OUR PRAYERS ARE WITH OUR FRIENDS
IN THE CAROLINAS.
NOW IT'S TIME FOR AN IMPORTANT
"HANNITY" WATCH ON THE RADICAL
SOCIALIST DEMOCRATS THAT WANT TO
BE THE NEXT PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
LAST NIGHT FAKE NEW CNN
DEDICATED A WHOPPING SEVEN LONG
MISERABLE HOURS TO ONE TOPIC:
CLIMATE CHANGE.
IT WAS ESSENTIALLY A MARATHON
INFOMERCIAL FOR THE DNC, ALL
THINGS DEMOCRAT.
FOR THE RECORD, THE RATINGS
FRANKLY SUCKED, MARGINALLY
BETTER FROM THEIR USUALLY
DISASTROUS NUMBERS BUT A FLOP, A
FAILURE BY ANY TV OBJECT OR
OBJECTIVE MEASURE.
THANKS TO YOU AND WE MEAN THIS
WITH OUR HEARTS AND SOULS,
THANK YOU FOR GIVING US THIS TV
SET EVERY NIGHT, JOINING US
EVERY NIGHT.
WE HAD WELL OVER 2 MILLION
VIEWERS MORE THAN THERE ARE
UNUSUALLY MARGINALLY HIGHER
NUMBER.
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
YOU MAKE THIS SHOW POSSIBLE.
WE NEVER FORGET THAT.
AT CNN, THE NETWORK PROVIDED TEN
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATES PLATFORM TO SHARE
THEIR RADICAL AND I MEAN RADICAL
PLANS FOR SAVING MOTHER EARTH
FROM ITS IMMINENT DESTRUCTION.
IT WAS ALL ONE BIG LIE, ONE
EXCUSE FOR DEMOCRATS AND OF
COURSE THE MEDIA MOB THAT
SUPPORTS THEM TO PUSH THEIR
RADICAL EXTREME SOCIALIST AGENDA
AND TRASH AMERICAN CAPITALISM
WHICH CREATED THE GREATEST
WEALTH IN HISTORY OF MANKIND.
DON'T BE FOOLED.
LAST NIGHT WAS NOT ABOUT CLEAN
AIR OR WATER.
IT WAS ABOUT GOVERNMENT,
COMPLETE AND TOTAL CONTROL OVER
OUR LIVES, YOUR LIVES.
THE CANDIDATES ON FAKE NEW CNN
MADE IT PERFECTLY CLEAR THEY
WANT TO CONTROL WHAT YOU EAT,
MAY BE INVESTED IN COWS.
HOW YOU COMMUTE TO WORK, WHAT
KIND OF JOB, WHAT KIND OF CAR
YOU DRIVE, HOW MUCH ENERGY YOU
CONSUME AND EVEN WHAT KIND OF --
I HAPPEN TO LOVE PLASTIC STRAWS
MYSELF.
WHETHER OR NOT YOU'RE ALLOWED
PLASTIC STRAWS.
ONE CANDIDATE PROPOSING USING
ABORTION AS A CONTROL OF
POPULATION IN POOR COUNTRIES.
PRETTY TWISTED, UGLY, SICK AND
FRANKLY REPULSIVE.
EVERY DEMOCRAT HEAPING PRAISE ON
THE GREEN NEW DEAL WHICH
ABOLISHES OUR FREE MARKET SYSTEM
IN EXCHANGE FOR FALSE ASSURANCES
TO ALLEVIATE ALL OF YOUR WORRIES
IN LIFE.
JUST LIKE KEEP YOUR DOCTOR, KEEP
YOUR PLAN AND SAVE MONEY.
DIDN'T HAPPEN.
JUST THINK SOLYNDRA.
A WASTE OF MONEY.
FREE HIGHER EDUCATION, FREE
HEALTH CARE, FREE VACATION, FREE
GREEN HOUSING, FREE HEALTHY
FOOD, UNIVERSAL BASIC INCOME,
YOU LOSE YOUR RIGHT TO PRIVATE
INSURANCE BUT WHO CARES, RIGHT?
ALSO CALLS FOR NO MORE HOUSE, NO
MORE AIR TRAVEL, NO MORE NUCLEAR
ENERGY, NO MORE COMBUSTION
ENGINE, NO MORE OIL AND GAS,
THE LIFEBLOOD OF EVERY ECONOMY
ESPECIALLY HOURS, AND THE ONE
THING THAT WILL RAISE THE
STANDARD OF LIVING OF EVERY
SINGLE AMERICAN, IF ONLY WOULD
WE USE OUR.
SHARE IT WITH THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
THIS PLAN WOULD SEND US INTO A
GREAT DEPRESSION PROBABLY WITHIN
HOURS OF ITS IMPLEMENTATION AND
GOT OUR INALIENABLE RIGHTS.
JUST A MOMENT, WERE GOING TO
SHOW YOU THE DUMB AND IN SOME
CASES SCARY AND CHILLING AND
FRIGHTENING PROPOSALS LAST
NIGHT'S TOWN HALL BUT FIRST WE
BRING IN SOME IMPORTANT CONTEXT
OF THE LEFT'S NONSTOP "THE SKY
IS FALLING" RHETORIC SURROUNDING
LAST NIGHT'S SEVEN LONG PATHETIC
I WAS ON CLIMATE CHANGE.
IT'S TIME FOR A "HANNITY"
HISTORY LESSON ON THE HORRIBLY
WRONG PREDICTIONS, FLAWED
SCIENCE, POLITICALLY MOTIVATED
OUTRAGE ABOUT THE FUTURE OF THIS
WONDERFUL PLANET.
YOU KNOW, REMEMBER GOD TOLD JOB
HE SET THE FOUNDATIONS FOR THE
EARTH.
THE MAJESTY OF GOD'S CREATION WE
CAN'T EVEN BEGIN TO FATHOM.
UNIVERSALISM WITHIN UNIVERSES
WITHIN UNIVERSES.
IN THE 1970s WE HAD LIBERAL,
CATS, SOCIALIST, PROMINENT
LIBERAL SCIENTIST, SO CALLED
SCHOLARS THAT WERE SOUNDING A
DESPERATE ALARM ABOUT THE COMING
ICE AGE AND GLOBAL COOLING.
ONE PROMINENT ECOLOGIST STATED
"IF THE PRESENT TRENDS CONTINUE,
THE WORLD WILL BE ABOUT
4 DEGREES COLDER FOR THE GLOBAL
MEAN TEMPERATURE IN 1990."
11 DEGREES COLDER IN THE YEAR
2000.
THIS IS ABOUT TWICE WHAT IT
WOULD TAKE TO PUT US INTO THAT
ICE AGE.
HARVARD BIOLOGIST GEORGE WHILE
CLAIMING "CIVILIZATIONAL END
WITHIN 15 OR 30 YEARS
UNLESS IMMEDIATE ACTION IS TAKEN
AGAINST THE PROBLEMS FACING
MANKIND."
THE MEDIA MOB ECHOING THE
SCIENTIFIC COMMUNITY'S PANIC.
1974, TAKE A LOOK.
TIME MAGAZINE WONDERING IF
ANOTHER ICE AGE IS ON THE WAY.
1975, "NEWSWEEK" DEDICATED A
MASSIVE REPORT TO THE "COOLING
WORLD."
OF COURSE THERE WAS NO ICE AGE
IN THE 90s, CIVILIZATION DID
NOT INDENT THE EXACT
OPPOSITE HAPPENED.
WORLDWIDE POPULATION BLUES, LIFE
EXPECTANCY INCREASED, STANDARD
OF LIVING AROUND THE GLOBE
IMPROVED DRAMATICALLY.
THAT AND STOP THE SO-CALLED
SCIENTIFIC COMMUNITY LIKE THE
SO-CALLED MEDIA AND DEMOCRATS
ARE MAKING WILD AND OF DAYS
PREDICTIONS, ONE AFTER ANOTHER.
THE AP, 1999 REPORTING "A SENIOR
U.N. ENVIRONMENTAL OFFICIAL SAYS
ENTIRE NATIONS COULD BE WIPED
OFF THE FACE OF THE EARTH BY THE
RISING SEA LEVELS."
NOW WANT TO GLOBAL WARMING, WE
LEFT THE ICE AGE.
IT'S A GLOBAL WARMING TREND
CLOVES NOT REVERSED BY THE YEAR
2000, 2006, REMEMBER AL GORE,
THE LUNATIC HE IS, WARNING THAT
UNLESS DRASTIC MEASURES ARE
TAKEN WITH THE NEXT TEN YEARS,
THE WORLD WILL REACH A POINT NO
RETURN.
WE'RE WAY PAST THE TEN-YEAR
MARK.
FOR DECADES, WE SAW ONE FALSE
DIRE WARNING AFTER ANOTHER.
OVER AND OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
A SMALL EXAMPLE, I CAN RUN THE
WHOLE HOUR ON THIS.
>> THE PLANET HAS A FEVER.
IF YOUR BABY HAS A FEVER, YOU GO
TO THE DOCTOR.
THIS IS WHAT WOULD HAPPEN TO
MANHATTAN.
THEY CAN MEASURE THIS PRECISELY.
JUST AS THE SCIENTISTS COULD
PREDICT PRECISELY HOW MUCH WATER
WOULD BREACH THE LEVEES IN
NEW ORLEANS.
THE AREA WHERE THE WORLD TRADE
CENTER MEMORIAL IS TO BE LOCATED
WOULD BE UNDERWATER.
>> ICE CAPS GOOD MELT, RAISING
THE LEVEL OF THE SEAS.
>> POSSIBLE, PROBABLE, WE REALLY
DON'T KNOW BUT IF IT HAPPENS, IT
MEANS GOODBYE, MIAMI.
GOODBYE, CORPUS CHRISTI.
GOODBYE, SACRAMENTO.
GOODBYE BOSTON.
>> ONE SCIENTIST WITH THE
URGENCY OF THE GREENHOUSE
POTENTIAL IN BIBLICAL TERMS.
CITING THE WARNING GIVEN TO NOAH
IN THE OLD TESTAMENT.
NO ONE KNEW TROUBLE WAS COMING,
HE SAID, AND HE PREPARED FOR IT.
>> Sean: THE MEDIA MOB BACK
THEN.
YOU SAW SOME FOOTAGE FROM
AL GORE'S "IN INCONVENIENT
TRUTH," IT WAS A BRITISH JUDGE
RULING THAT THE FILM WAS NOT
SUITABLE FOR KIDS IN CLASSROOMS
BECAUSE OF ALL OF ITS
FALSE CLAIMS.
ONE SUCH CLAIM INVOLVED FULLY
BEARS.
AL GORE IMPLIED THAT THE ANIMALS
WERE A DOOMED SPECIES.
TODAY POLAR BEARS ARE SEEING AN
EXPLOSION IN POPULATION AND
RECENTLY THE LEFT HAS BLAMED ALL
EXTREME WEATHER -- OKAY, THERE'S
NO MORE COOLING OF THE EARTH.
THERE IS NO ICE AGE.
WERE NOT GOING TO BURN OUT.
SO WE WILL SAY CLIMATE CHANGE
AND THAT WILL BE IF HE GETS HOT
OR COLD, WE CAN SAY IT'S CLIMATE
CHANGE AND WE ARE RESPONSIBLE.
THEY CLAIM THE MOTHERS BECOME
WORSE, KILLING AMERICANS IN
INCREASING NUMBERS.
THAT TOO IS A LIE.
TAKE A LOOK AT SCREEN.
2018, FEWER AMERICANS KILLED BY
FLOODS, LIGHTNING, TORNADOES,
HURRICANES, AND HEAT THAN THE
30-YEAR NATIONAL AVERAGE.
DON'T GET ME WRONG.
I BELIEVE WE SHOULD BE GOOD
STEWARDS OF GOD'S GIFTS.
CLEAN AIR, WATER, IMPORTANT.
BUT WE ARE NOT DEALING WITH THE
APOCALYPTIC SCENARIO THEY KEEP
LAYING OUT.
ON FAKE NEWS CNN LAST NIGHT,
NONE OF THESE FACTS SEEMED TO
MATTER.
WOLF BLITZER WENT FULL ON
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ ON US
AND EVEN BLAMED HURRICANE DORIAN
WHICH IS IN HURRICANE SEASON IN
HURRICANE PRONE AREA OF THE
WORLD ON CLIMATE CHANGE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE HAVE 11 YEARS TO AVOID THE
CATASTROPHIC CONSEQUENCES OF
THIS CRISIS.
FOOD SHORTAGES, RISING SEA
LEVELS, MORE EXTREME WEATHER
EVENTS LIKE HURRICANE DORIAN
THAT'S TURNING TOWARDS THE
CAROLINAS RIGHT NOW.
>> Sean: WOLF, STICK TO THE
CONSPIRACY THEORIES, WHAT WE ARE
USED TO.
THAT CLAIM IS PRETTY STUPID BUT
IT ONLY GOT WORSE FROM THERE.
NATURALLY YOU HAVE SLEEPY CREEPY
CRAZY WELL, JOE RIO 330 BIDEN.
THE EYES FILLED WITH BLOOD KIND
OF RAMBLING INCOHERENTLY LAST
NIGHT BUT EVEN WORSE, MULTIPLE
CANDIDATES ON THE STAGE OR
COMPARING STRUGGLES AGAINST
SO-CALLED CLIMATE CHANGE TO
AMERICA'S FIGHT AGAINST NAZI
GERMANY IN WORLD WAR II.
NAZISM, FASCISM, JAPAN, REALLY?
MAYOR PETE?
>> ONE OF THE REASONS I LOVE THE
FRAMING OF THE GREEN NEW DEAL IS
IT USES SOME OF THE LANGUAGE
THAT WE MIGHT ASSOCIATE WITH THE
WAY THAT WE MET THE RESPONSE OF
NAZI GERMANY.
>> JUST LIKE THE GREATEST
GENERATION WON WORLD WAR II AND
JUST LIKE THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT.
IT'S OUR CHALLENGE.
>> THIS IS THE HARDEST THING WE
WILL HAVE DONE IN MY LIFETIME AS
A COUNTRY.
IT'S ON PAR WITH WINNING
WORLD WAR II.
PERHAPS EVEN MORE CHALLENGING
THAN THAT.
>> Sean: WHY DON'T YOU TRY
GOVERNING SOUTH BEND, INDIANA,
FIRST BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT DOING A
GREAT JOB THERE.
MORE CHALLENGING THAN WINNING
WORLD WAR II?
MY FATHER FOUGHT FOR YEARS IN
THE PACIFIC.
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE DIED IN
WORLD WAR II.
MAYOR PETE AND THE OTHERS WANT
TO TELL THE GREATEST GENERATION
THAT DRIVING A PREVIOUS IS
TOUGHER THAN STORMING THE
BEACHES OF NORMANDY, DOES HE
NEED TO RE-LEARN THE HORRORS OF
THE HOLOCAUST JUST LIKE THE
SQUAD MEMBERS THAT REGULATE
COMPARE WELL, A LOT OF THINGS
THAT NAZI CONCENTRATION CAMPS?
DOES CLIMATE CHANGE HYSTERIA AS
PRETTY INSULTING AND SO ARE THE
DEMOCRATS RADICAL PLANS TO
BATTLE THIS BIG CRISIS.
THEY WANT TO BAN REGULATE PRETTY
MUCH EVERYTHING YOU CAN
THINK OF.
WE HAVE THE TAPE TO PROVE IT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT OFFSHORE
DRILLING FOR OIL.
WOULD YOU BAN IT?
THEY GO ABSOLUTELY.
>> WOULD YOU BAN OFFSHORE
DRILLING?
>> ABSOLUTELY YES.
I WILL BAN OFFSHORE DRILLING.
>> WOULD YOU BAN OFFSHORE
DRILLING?
>> YES.
THERE'S NO QUESTION I'M IN FAVOR
OF BANNING FRACKING.
>> STRASSER A A BIG THING.
DO YOU BAN PLASTIC STRAWS
QUESTION MARKS TO GOD THAT WE
SHOULD.
>> LAUGHED AND FACTORY FARMING
BECAUSE THAT'S NOT ONLY -- IT'S
A DANGER TO THE ENVIRONMENT
AND CLIMATE CHANGE.
>> COAL BURNING PLANTS.
NO ONE IS GOING TO BUILD IN THE
COAL BURNING PLANT.
WE ARE GOING TO SHUT THE ONES
DON'T HAVE BUT NO ONE'S GOING TO
BUILD A NEW ONE.
WE HAVE TO TAKE COMBUSTION
ENGINE VEHICLES OFF THE ROAD AS
RAPIDLY AS WE CAN.
>> Sean: EXCUSE ME.
WE CAN MOCK THE PROPOSED BANS ON
MY FAVORITE PLASTIC STRAW AND
BURGERS BUT THE CALL TO A
LIMITED OIL AND GAS PRODUCTION,
OKAY, THAT WOULD BE A DEATH BLOW
TO OUR ECONOMY.
PLUS IT WOULD BE A MASSIVE GIFT
TO VLADIMIR PUTIN.
YOU KNOW THE HOSTILE ACTOR WHO
RUNS A HOSTELRY G-MAN RUSSIA?
THE SAME RATIONALE THAT
HILLARY CLINTON GOT HER LYING
DOSSIER FROM TO TRY TO RIG THE
ELECTION?
HIS HOSTILE REGIME DEPENDS ON
ONE THING: OIL AND GAS.
A DECREASE IN AMERICAN OIL
PRODUCTION, THAT WOULD MEAN
RUSSIA WOULD DOMINATE THE
MARKET.
THAT WOULD STRENGTHENING PUTIN'S
AUTHORITY IN EUROPE.
IS THAT WHAT THE DEMOCRATS WANT?
IN CASE YOU'RE WONDERING, THE
PRICE TAG OF THE DEMOCRATS
CLIMATE CHANGE PROPOSAL, WELL,
THAT'S TOTALLY IN SAINT TOO.
LOOK AT THESE NUMBERS.
>> ARE GOING TO HAVE TO SPEND A
LOT OF FEDERAL MONEY.
>> $250 BILLION IMMEDIATELY.
>> YOUR CLIMATE CHANGE PLAN.
>> A $1 TRILLION PLAN.
>> SENATOR BOOKER, UNIVERSALLY
UNVEILED A $3 TRILLION PLAN TO
TACKLE CLIMATE CHANGE.
>> $5 TRILLION.
>> $16 TRILLION.
>> Sean: FOR CONTEXT, THE
ENTIRE FEDERAL BUDGET IS AROUND
$4 TRILLION A YEAR.
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
EACH AND EVERY CANDIDATE, THEY
WANT TO ADD TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS
THE SPENDING.
THAT MEANS TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN NEW TAXES IN AN ECONOMY THAT
YOU'RE DESTROYING.
MOST OF THE CANDIDATES SUPPORT A
VARIETY OF OTHER NEW TAXES,
INCOME TAXES, SALES TAXES,
CARBON TAXES, WEALTH TAXES.
IT WOULD DRAMATICALLY INCREASE
THE CARBON TAX, THE COST OF
ENERGY FOR EVERY AMERICAN.
CORPORATIONS DON'T PAY TAXES.
THEY PASS THE COST ON THE AU
PAIR THAT CARBON TAX, THAT
WOULDN'T EVEN BE ENOUGH OF
BERNIE'S PLAN.
$16 TRILLION, TRILLION WITH A T,
NEW SPENDING JUST ON PROGRAMS.
BERNIE SANDERS, ALSO SEEMS TO
ECHO THE SICK AND TWISTED AND
VILE PHILOSOPHY OF PLANNED
PARENTHOOD FOUNDER MARGARET
SANGER WITH HIS SICK, OLD GLEE
PULLS
SUPPORT FOR ABORTION.
IS THIS THE NEW
DEMOCRATIC PARTY?
TAKE A LOOK?
>> EDUCATING EVERYONE ON THE
NEED TO CURB POPULATION GROWTH
SEEMS REASONABLE CAMPAIGN TO
ENACT.
WOULD YOU BE COURAGEOUS ENOUGH
TO DISCUSS THIS ISSUE AND MAKE
IT A KEY FEATURE OF A CLIENT TO
ADDRESS CLIMATE CATASTROPHE?
>> MARTHA, THE ANSWER IS YES.
THE ANSWER HAS EVERYTHING TO DO
WITH THE FACT THAT WOMEN IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA BY THE
WAY HAVE A RIGHT TO CONTROL
THEIR OWN BODIES.
ESPECIALLY IN POOR COUNTRIES
AROUND THE WORLD.
WHERE WOMEN DO NOT NECESSARILY
WANT TO HAVE LARGE NUMBERS OF
BABIES.
WHERE THEY CAN HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY THROUGH BIRTH
CONTROL TO CONTROL THE NUMBER OF
KIDS THEY HAVE.
SOMETHING I VERY, VERY STRONG
SUPPORT.
>> Sean: IS AT THE NEW
DEMOCRATIC PARTY?
DOES IT PRETTY MUCH SUM OF THE
NIGHT AT FAKE NEW CNN?
I THINK SO.
DEMOCRATS, CLIMATE CHANGE.
IT'S ONLY A POLITICAL TOOL, EVEN
THE CHIEF OF STAFF OF
OCASIO-CORTEZ RECOGNIZED AND
STATED PUBLICLY, DESIGNED TO
TRICK YOU TO GIVE UP YOUR
LIBERTY AND YOUR FREEDOM AND A
LOT OF YOUR TAX MONEY.
DEMOCRATS CAN ENACT THEIR VISION
OF A SOCIALIST UTOPIA AND SO
PEOPLE LEAVE NEW YORK,
NEW JERSEY, THEY WILL BELIEVING
TRICK WILL AMERICA IF THIS IS
AND PREVENTIVE.
THIS ELECTION IS THE BIGGEST
CHOICE OF OUR LIFETIMES.
IT'S ABOUT LIVING FREE OR
AMERICA AS WE KNOW IT DIES ON
THE FUTURE OF OUR COUNTRY, THEIR
FREE WORLD IS AT STAKE.
BEFORE WE GET TO OUR GUESTS, LET
ME ADDRESS ONE GLARING EXAMPLE
OF FAKE NEWS MEDIA BIAS PRETTY
MUCH EVERY NEWSROOM IN AMERICA
SCREW THIS UP.
AND LIE TO YOU BY ACCUSING THE
PRESIDENT OF LYING.
THIS IS FROM AUGUST 29TH AND
30TH PROVING THE PRESIDENT, WHAT
HE SAID ABOUT THE MODELS OF
HURRICANE DORIAN, THAT IT MIGHT
HIT ALABAMA, IT'S TRUE.
BUT IF YOU WATCH THE MEDIA MOB,
YOU WOULD THINK THE PRESIDENT IS
LYING, AS THEY ALWAYS DO.
AN ABSURD EXAMPLE OF TRUMP
DERANGEMENT SYNDROME.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE IS FALSIFYING
WEATHER REPORTS SO IT DOESN'T
HAVE TO ADMIT THE PRESIDENT
SPENT THE WEEKEND GOLFING AND
WAS NOT UP-TO-DATE ON THE STORMS
FORECAST.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS NOT THE
SHARPEST SHARPIE.
>> IT FITS A PATTERN OF THE
PRESIDENT PUTTING OUT MISLEADING
INFORMATION.
>> THE INITIAL REACTION IS TO
LAUGH OUT LOUD.
IT'S SO ABSURD.
THE OTHER ASPECT BORDERS ON
BEING TRULY DANGEROUS.
>> DEMOCRATS KEEP LOOKING FOR AN
IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY.
THIS IS AGAINST THE LAW.
THIS MIGHT ACTUALLY BE CRUMBS